this will be a 3d video series on the
male reproductive Anatomy in this video
we will study the anatomy of the testes
and the epididymis in subsequent videos
we will cover the anatomy of the
prostate the seminal vesicles vas
deferens and the penis so let's first
start with the anatomy of the testes for
making the anatomy of the testes clear
less force dissect out the penis so now
we have a clear view of the testes so
let's get right from the anatomy of
today's tease so as you can see this is
the right test ace and this is the left
testes the left testes is at a slightly
lower level than the right testes
talking about the dimensions the testes
is 3.75 centimeters long 2.5 centimeters
broad and 1.8 centimeters thick it
weighs approximately 10 to 15 grams
talking about the grass anatomy of the
testes it has two poles the upper Pole
and the lower Pole it has two borders
the anterior border and the posterior
border and it has two surfaces this is
the medial surface and this is the
lateral surface and as you can see on
the upper pole of the testes this
structure is the epididymis about which
we will talk later in this video
so this is the cross section of the
testes which shows its internal
structure the testes is covered by three
layers this is the Tunica vaginalis this
is the outermost layer and this is the
lower persistent part of the processor's
vaginalis inner to the Tunica vaginalis
is the tunica albuginea this membrane
which you see here this is a wide dense
fibrous membrane and covers the testes
all around and at the posterior border
of the testes which I will highlight
here this is the posterior border this
tunica albuginea is thickened to form a
vertical dredge known as a media center
of the
so this is the mediastinum of the testes
and from this mediastinum various septae
pass into the internal structure of the
testes which divide the testes into
various lobules and the innermost
covering of the testes is the tunica
vasculature which is the vascular core
of the testes which lines the lobules of
the testes talking about its internal
part as you can see the testes is
divided into approximately 200 to 350
lobules like this and each lobule
consists of 2 to 3 seminiferous tubules
so these are the seminiferous tubules
and the lining of the seminiferous
tubules consists of germ cells in
various development phases so as you can
see these seminal ferrous tubules
converge at the purposes of these
lobules
and they form 20 to 30 straight tubules
and these straight tubules enter the
mediastinum of the testes and freely
anastomosis with each other and they
form a single coiled structure known as
the ureter testes and the rated testes
gives rise to these efferent tubules
which you see right here these are the
efferent tubules these are 15 to 20
number they exit the testes through the
superior pole and they form the single
tube you'll which is highly coiled on
itself to form the epididymis so talking
about the blood supply of the testes the
testes is supplied by a set of
testicular arteries this you see right
here is the right testicular artery and
this is the left testicular artery about
their origin they arise from the aorta
at the level of second number vertebra
so as you can see right here this is the
point of origin of the testicle arteries
let me dissect out some extra vessels
from this area so you can have a clear
view regarding the origin of the
testicle arteries so as you can see this
is the point of origin of the right
testicle artery and this is the left
testicular artery they both arise at the
level of the second number were dobrze
which is highlighted here
about the venous drainage of the testes
the testes is drained by two set of
veins this is the right testicle arraign
and this is the left testicular vein
talking first about the right testicular
way in this a sense upwards follows same
course as the testicular artery and it
ascends up words added inserts into the
inferior vena cava at the level of first
lumbar vertebra now the insertion of the
left testicular wayne is different from
that of the right testicle arraign the
left testicle Irwin follows a same
course that of the opposite Wain but it
does not drain into the inferior vena
cava it drains into the left renal vein
so this is you see here is the point of
insertion of the left testicle Irwin
into the left renal vein this is the
point of insertion talking about the
lymphatic drainage of the testes the
testes are mainly drained by the
priority group of lymph nodes so these
group of lymph nodes are the pre or tech
lymph nodes
they are also drained by the para erotic
lymph nodes now let's talk about the
anatomy of the epididymis so as you can
see this is the epididymis which lies on
the upper pole of the testes what
happens in different duck tails which
emerge out of the testes which are
approximately 1513 number they exit to
the upper Pole and the forms single tube
you'll which is highly coiled on itself
and it forms the appeared miss the
epididymis can consists of three parts
this is the head of the epididymis which
is attached to the upper pole of the
testes this is the body of the
epididymis and this is the tail of the
epididymis the tail of the appearance is
continuous with the ductus deferens or
the vas deferens and the epididymis is
also supplied by the testicular artery
so this was a brief anatomy of the
testes and the epididymis in the next
part of this video we will study anatomy
of the ductus deferens and the seminal
vesicles
make sure to check out the next video in
this series to
Stan other parts of the male
reproductive system if you find this
video informative don't forget to hit
the like button below and also make sure
to subscribe to the channel for further
upcoming videos thank you so much for
watching this video